logan paul just launched cryptozoo his
latest crypto project and i need to get
you up to speed basically it's looking
like what happens when you give a
five-year-old some photoshop some photos
match together and somehow they sell it
for millions of dollars now in some ways
this might actually be more embarrassing
than dink doink logan's last project and
that's really saying something let's
just get into it ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the 10 million dollar studio
i'm your host coffee zilla the internet
detective now before we begin let me say
first of all pump the stock it's free so
getting into this video let me say some
of you uh will want to judge logan paul
after i tell you what i found out but i
need you to cut him some slack it's not
easy paying four percent taxes in puerto
rico the pandemic has truly hit everyone
logan's hurting and he needs the extra
cash so i need you to keep that in mind
while we talk about his latest project
so look i'm gonna make an in-depth video
on this but uh this is like a first look
at
cryptozoo logan paul's newest project
like i said it's hot off the heels of
dink doink which cratered almost
immediately losing millions of dollars
and losing logan as i guess their
ambassador
but never to let fans losses hold him
down logan immediately has pivoted to
his latest project being cryptozoo and
i'm gonna be honest logan at this point
isn't carrying a lot of water with me
when it comes to crypto i like when
you're the guy behind this
when you're behind that your next crypto
projects are going to carry a certain
scammy vibe but almost immediately logan
said that this time
it's different this is a project he
believes in that he's invested in i
think there needs to be a fresh take
and this project that i have uh is that
fresh take we have
a massive team behind it and are
probably out of pocket like a million
just because we believe it's gonna work
wow one million dollars already invested
in this project so what is cryptozoo
actually about looking at their official
white paper they say cryptozoo is an
autonomous ecosystem where users can
collect breed and trade exotic animals
on the blockchain so basically it's an
nft breeding game and i want to tell you
right away this is not a fresh take uh
tons of these exist crypto kitties axia
infinity wave dunks there are millions
of these so basically cryptozoo is logan
paul's own spin on this idea the idea is
you buy an egg it hatches into a base
set you breed it trade it logan calls it
a game and he insists that it will make
you money it's a really fun game that
makes you money now setting aside the
highly sketchy fact that you're going to
make money from this when in actuality
the real person is going to make money
is logan paul and setting aside the fact
that the concept's far from unique i
guess the real draw here is that someone
of logan's resources should be making a
very polished game right like this
should be some amazing artwork so when i
went to check the game out i set my
preconceived notions about logan aside i
said hey maybe he really tried on this
one maybe he's really giving this one a
fair shake so i went to check out what a
million dollar game looks like i went to
their instagram and to my surprise the
photos of cryptozoo
are basically a bunch of stock photos
from adobe that have been poorly
photoshopped ladies and gentlemen i mean
look at this
penguin plus shark penguin shark
need i say more uh video over actually
work video no that's it
look these are adobe photoshopped stock
photos ladies and gentlemen poorly
photoshopped might i add like look look
at their white paper meet the panda font
and then you have this abomination
the naming is about as original as the
artwork which is not at all now to
confirm these were taken from adobe i
went and i hunted down this exact image
and here it is cute giant panda bear
climbing in a tree does it look familiar
ladies and gentlemen can you see
similarities here can you tell that this
is the same exact image i mean look at
this point logan paul is creating
squidward levels of art here he's taking
someone else's work slapping a nose on
it and calling it art and then selling
the idea for millions of dollars to his
fans and look maybe you're thinking this
can't be true no way the guy who created
the artistic masterpiece dink doink
would be so lazy as to make nfts out of
stock photos i mean look at his already
legendary contributions to the crypto
space
my beloved assistant and
dick doink what's up
hey get your hands off my boss's dink
doink quick logan distract them with
your biceps
[Applause]
ah yes
comedy but anyways i went through a lot
of these photos they released like the
penguin shark and found the accompanying
stock photo they basically took from
they called this one the litton because
it's a lion and a kitten get it but
either no one noticed or no one cared
because when these crypto eggs were
released everyone immediately bought
them within minutes and i calculated how
much this netted all logan paul and it's
1.3 million dollars on ethereum alone
and half a million dollars
on bmb and this is before the game has
even launched this man managed to
convince you guys that stock photos were
worth a million dollars so of course
when i found all this out i did what any
self-respecting person would do i posted
my findings on twitter and immediately
their telegram was furious asking their
admin bin roth for answers so any truth
to the adobe stock rumors can you
confirm that the whole adobe stock fun
news is fake this is important to in the
adobe stock foot just didn't make an
announcement about this bin roth so it's
safe to say these guys were in pretty
hot water with their dear investors and
eventually after mounting pressure the
crypto team responded these nfts are not
adobe stock all of the nfts we created
are specifically designed by us and our
team wow okay interesting maybe i'm
confused maybe i'm the one confused
maybe these are just placeholder images
and they aren't nfts at all
in fact their own investors hopped up on
opium speculated that this was maybe
logan's 10 000 iq play so all images are
a decoy and logan is shooting youtube
video for dropping the mic on all the
futters
oh yeah logan's gonna drop the mic on
right i get this the admins actually
played into this idea maybe all the
pictures are a decoy says the krypto zoo
telegram team wow maybe i'm getting
trolled here maybe logan's million
dollar artist didn't just pull from
photoshop and mash two photos together
maybe i've fallen
for their trap card so i kept looking at
bin roth's other messages he is one of
the admins after all uh and that's when
i found this someone asking for an
actual real in-game nft no more of these
teasers and to my shock ladies and
gentlemen ben roth agrees to show what
drum roll please guys here it is
the million dollar art that logan paul
has created that's going to make all of
you rich this is it guys this is uh one
of their hybrids a totally original
definitely not photoshopped stock photo
but actually hang on this this does look
a little familiar
it's quick to make a digital asset with
you know unique randomly generated
characteristics
we
handmade
art for the past six months bro
approval very specific notes 10
different artists making art for our
project
oops guys call me crazy but i think that
these two stock photos together kind of
make this but to be sure this is really
true i'm gonna try to create this art
myself replicate it see how hard it
really is to make million dollars art in
photoshop
[Music]
time
well what do you guys think how do you
think it stacks up against the
million-dollar art here would you pay
1.3 million dollars for this right here
let you guys let me know in the comments
below because i'm thinking of quitting
my job and asking logan paul if i can
have a job with him work for him as an
artist
now later on bin roth seems to sort of
admit that these images are maybe stock
photos by saying that if they were stock
photos they would definitely be licensed
stock photos guys they're licensed okay
so you bought a license yes absolutely
wow
and that all but confirms it ladies and
gentlemen everyone who bought these eggs
or invested in zoo um you should have
invested in adobe because that's what
you're getting a combination of adobe
stock photos and adobe photoshop and
you're paying hundreds of dollars for it
i mean at this point why not cut out the
middleman and actually get a valuable
asset i mean because what else are you
getting with logan paul it's quick to
make a digital asset with
you know unique randomly generated
characteristics
we
handmade
art for the past six months bro approval
very specific notes 10 different artists
making art for our project 10 different
artists making art
for this project they handmade how's
that handmade art looking now guys
[Music]
it's beautiful ah i mean uh this isn't
us nft i put nft takes
more time you can't just nfc willy nilly
you gotta go by the book besides you got
the nose wrong
[Music]
what a shame what a shame you're a fraud
are you the same as so you're saying no
you're not